the mood in this market in bongi is just
right
for christmas festivities central
africans take their celebrations
seriously
and traders are making a killing it's
also an election season
they go to the polls on sunday and the
main worry is security
we are concerned about our safety of
course but it's christmas
and who doesn't want a good cheer
not everyone is in a festive mood though
many residents want to get their voices
hard
some through religious processions
praying for peace
[Music]
[Applause]
others like these women condemned the
newly formed patriots for change
a coalition of several armed groups but
has threatened to march to the city
and is already causing havoc in the
countryside
since 1966 our country has gone through
coups
rebellions mutinies and each time it
sets us back
the 2013 conflict brought us a lot of
sorrow
women have been raped many people have
died and others displaced
they are hoping that the 12 000 u.n
peacekeepers in the country
alongside government troops and other
international forces
will keep the patriots for change at bay
they're saying they just want a peaceful
election
this is a country that has been in
conflict for so long
and the humanitarian needs are huge more
than half the population
need some form of aids and hundreds of
thousands of central africans are
refugees
in neighboring countries car has
survived five crews amid constant
instability
since gaining independence from france
in 1960
the latest conflict started about seven
years ago when the then
president francois bozize was overthrown
by a mostly muslim-armed group
called celica reprisals by the mainly
christian antibalaca
only made things worse a peace deal
signed between 14 rebel groups and the
government
in 2019 brought about some calm
but now violence is again on the rise
we have the poorest people now hiding in
rural areas they are scared
they are in anguish as a father a man of
the church
i ask those who have picked up weapons
to have pity on us
all the presidential candidates are
promising peace
many central africans say they're tired
of broken promises
but here at the market they tell us they
want to take the weight of their
country's politics
off their shoulders for just a little
while
to have a merry christmas catherine soy
al jazeera
bongi